welcome to this video and playing
international master Istani from Ireland
right Island yeah to 35 major ated and
it's alex our study lopez it's not too
Irish first first impression okay let's
play this back eh phone line I don't
know any good line against the groom fun
anyway I mean I know lines that are good
but I don't know them like the queen bee
three line which is good as I
recommended this mi um somebody with a
d4 repertoire series but a choice the
latest fashion and it's really a bit
weird but interesting with um okay so i
usually play d take c5 you had this in a
couple of games already but someone
suggested to me that h5 is also move
here so let's um let's try h5 yeah after
this I'm going to go each sixes one of
the really strange things about this
line wow this is the cyst completely
crazy Bishop h6e takes on c3 mm-hmm ok
but so Bishop g7 s-sir is really
nonsense and so I probably have to
recapture
so but the bishop on h6 I have prevented
him from castling and done yeah but a
position if I go wait wait wait wait
just I thought Bishop g7 Quincy 392 rock
g8 I can play rock age seven which is
really wacky because of this pin okay
let's do that completely if completely
crazy I'm fianchetto enjoy 70mm this is
cool the analog age 7 was my idea is it
really working mm-hmm we can take on g7
maybe take 27 rock g7 and King evade my
rocket strapped this is annoying okay so
probably I need to play whoopsie one
here unfortunately
yeah this line is really funny if you
get completely completely weird and
unexplored purchase positions on after
just a couple of moves came let's take
here right or not or should I take on f6
this is maybe better I need to do this
anyway and I better do it now in a
position way is actually forced to to
take on the type of the pawn okay so
what about rook age 32 III is this good
I could take Suzie h7 but the rukon III
is strong immediately using using the
piece or maybe Roxy three groups III is
the far more dangerous thing attacking
the the bishop and now if for
yes I need to I need to use all my
pieces also the f1 bishop yeah he's just
grabbing everything
love to get the Queen to 2d6 this would
be enormous if I managed that
and Queen Queen f3 maybe this one
attacking your six it's hard to play
because I have fun quite quite a number
of interesting interesting options no
it's not clear what the most promising
is
yeah it's probably not enough this looks
um yeah it looks like compensation but
it doesn't look like a decisive a
decisive attack
hmm yeah I must have done something
something something bad here I think at
the at the start this was very promising
after this position 14 ok check ok yeah
I need to analyze it afterwards at least
do this quick computer check what is the
same two poles down here two pawns even
if I just got one back i thought i was
just one fall down yeah two points as is
too much he could just play king evade
yeah i'm not sure why i didn't play king
of it would have been quite quite simple
yeah ok i'm not saying that this is so
this is great for me but
yeah it is probably excellent for for
black as well gathers just good home
yeah okay yes so it was it was it was
really not not a matter of precise play
could basically play anything what the
heck probably rock age three was was was
a bad idea after all
check time warning huh yeah that's it
still lost coming Roxy for Jackie's
doing everything to make it make it
interesting but I'm download 14 seconds
check
yeah okay come on I could have resigned
quite a while ago white resigned yeah
this was quite stupid up i'm pretty sure
actually when i played rook 83 i didn't
really pay attention that define was
saying you got player play just before I
just haven't know whatever i'm basically
winning here my life is I'm are clearly
better I mean it's a it's yet just one
cornea just one porn yeah and a half
excellent excellent compensation efore I
could just I can also take age seven so
it's very good for white it's just got a
very uncoordinated position but then it
was it was a bad idea to to give away d
50 Queen a force actually strong but ok
that's I thought that that this would
would give me compensation young Nazi
for again leads to a good game yeah it's
difficult it's the kind of position
where you are it's pretty obvious that
white has has a strong strong attacker
or strong initiative but you need to
play all those precise move and i didn't
i didn't manage that i played the
similar idea but not in up in a precise
manner the show just leads to to a loss
I probably should have should have tried
that this is a bit better but yeah it's
it's two pawns for black and maybe have
compensation for one part but not not
too so again an interesting position out
of this wacky opening but I have simply
wasn't up to playing the writer the
right moves one funny line I I just want
to put on the board here my original
idea here after Luke g8 wait
Queen takes 92 group g8 was rook age 7
which is not working because of route
takes rook takes King evade and distract
otherwise this would have been quite
interesting route page 7 but okay it
wasn't it was necessary at all yeah this
was good I mean just leading two to a
pretty substantial edge for white but ok
I put inflate played well afterwards
thanks for watching